in a world where virtual collaboration
and digital transformation
is increasingly important for
organizations finding better ways that
your team can leverage technology to
work more efficiently
is critical to success this is
especially true for desk-less workers
who are out on the floor or
in the field and not at a computer for
these people
it can be challenging to create
solutions that address their needs
luckily google cloud is here to help
we'll show how a team of field
technicians can leverage
google cloud products to boost their
productivity
in just a few minutes you should be able
to walk away with some new ideas of how
you can harness the power of technology
to improve the way you and your team
works
meet julia julia manages a team of
appliance repair experts who respond to
dozens of job requests each day
julia needs an easy way to communicate
with her team
manage the job requests and contracts
and provide her team with the resources
they need to do their job
so how does she do it well in just a
couple days
julia has used app sheet google cloud's
no code application development platform
to create a simple app to help her
manage all these tasks
she shared this app with her team so
they can all collaborate around it
the first task julia needs to complete
is to be able to communicate with her
team
julia has set up a virtual daily
stand-up for her team that can be joined
by selecting
daily stand-up then clicking on today's
event
this opens up a google meet julia can
then discuss over video chat the key
items and each member of her team can
share their plan for the action of the
day
customers fill out new job requests
through google forms
and as the requests come in they will
show up in the jobs
section of julia's app she can then
assign them to the different technicians
and they can work with the customer to
schedule and complete the repair
when a technician picks up a job they're
able to easily create a job contract in
the app
they simply fill out some key
information
[Music]
sign it and save it
the app then automatically updates a
template that was created in google docs
with the appropriate information
and sends it to julia and the customer
this app
links directly to a google sheet so
anytime julia or her team
makes updates to the app the sheet is
updated with the new information
this makes it easy for julia to manage
her data and know where
everything is stored as the technician
works on a repair
they're able to access the manuals and
repair guides associated with that
product
which have been uploaded to the drive
and linked in the app
this makes it easy for her team to
access the documentation they need while
on the job
finally as the technician completes a
job they're able to update its status
with details
pictures and even annotations
these types of apps aren't just useful
for appliance repair teams
they can be used by construction workers
inspectors
healthcare workers public service
representatives and more
using these google cloud platforms
creating processes such as these can
take
days or weeks not months or years to
create
allowing businesses to work faster and
better
to learn more and to access this and
other app templates
click on the link below
[Music]
you